IN OVER THE LINE.
THERE IS ST.SKATE, AND TO
CENTERINGS IT IN OVER THE LINE.
SWINGS WIDE, TRIED TO GET IT IN
WITH A SHOT
TO THE LET BY JOKIHARJU, AND AS
SOON
KRUG SUSN'TS IT UP, AND HE GET
KNOCKED DOWN, SWEPT AHEAD, AND A
SHOT, THEY WALL, AFTER
WINNING THAT BATTLE,
BOARDS, S LOOSE.
YOU SEE THE STEPPING IN, AND PO
GOING TO GET THIS PUCK.
FESAAD,
AND A RETURN  IT IN AND
COMES AFTER IT AGAIN, AND
CLEARED IT OUT IN
CO
MITTELSTADT, AND BUTCHER FIRES
IT WIDE, AND
>> Rob: GREAT PUSH BY CORNER AN
RIGHT THERE TO GET IT BY
ANDERSON WHO IS THERE,
A CHANG.
BOTH TEAMS GET A LINE.
HE DOES A NICE JOB GETTING IN
TIGHT, AND GETTING A
AGAIN, AND THEY SCORE.
THAT IS JAMMED IN AT THE SIDE OF
THE NECH.
BUCHNEVICH I THINK GOT A HAND O
BACK THROUGH.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THAT, YEAH,
IN, AND
MADE IT BECAUSE IT WAS SHOT
UNDER HIM.
>> Rob: THE PUCK RIGHT THERE BY
THE THE THOMPSON, AND
GETS AROUND TO THE